[Música]
y
la primera pregunta que se me vino
mientras estábamos discutiendo
sus vidas es que me cuenten eso cuando
eran niñas ustedes pensaron estar donde
están que en que soñaban cuando eran
niñas que querían ser cuando eran niñas
bueno yo desde muy niña siempre soñaba
con algún momento de mi juventud pues
llegar y tocar el cielo estaré en la
cima desde muy niña mi papá siempre me
llevaba en sus actividades donde todos
eran hombres y me daba miedo no decía
por hombre yo que voy a hacer ahí
pero decía no eso no me va a impedir
algún momento cuando ya sea más grande
voy a subir a la cima y siempre estaba
con ese sueño de un sueño de niña que yo
que yo siempre tenía y cuando llegó a la
cumbre recuerdo esos momentos qué rol
juega su familia sus esposos sus papás a
veces para el apoyo de que ustedes
logren esto porque mencionabas que era
antes eran puro hombres o sentías miedo
por la seguridad porque es tan
importante y el rol que juegan ellos
bueno en personalmente mi papá
siempre me ha inspirado mucho sueño de
ser siempre como él y el apoyo gran
apoyo que siempre él nos ha dado
en la pasada se siempre ha sido un poco
machista de decir es de trabajos para
hombres no cuando hemos empezado hemos
sufrido mucho de eso es decir que van a
poder pero llegado el momento cuando ya
seamos cumbre volvíamos no nos decía ya
nada muchos en el entorno
[Aplausos]
y el apoyo de la familia siempre ha sido
muy importante los amigos del entorno
los aplausos una foto cuando íbamos de
un lado al otro la de entonces todo eso
siempre nos ha a mí personalmente
ayudado a continuar tal vez también
lidiaba completa lidia
la importancia de la familia de la
pareja con el yo como como fue bueno
para mí
la familia es muy importante aquí mi
esposo a eulalio gonzález el de la guía
guía de alta montaña trabajaba con los
turistas guía bayern buenas según de eso
yo también he empezado a trabajar junto
con él y hoy cocinaba para los turistas
no en alta montaña a 5200 metros sobre
el nivel del mar y bueno
algo así ha nacido no también partía de
mi familia tengo dos lindas hijas y
bueno una de mis hijas también es otra
cholita escaladora bueno creo que
trabajamos en familia y más unidos y nos
damos más fuerza para poder sí seguir
haciendo más montañas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
también conversando yo pensaba en muchas
de ustedes me han comentado tienen estas
ganas de hacer ocho cumbres llevan 78
y a veces muy normal
como está aquí esta hermosa foto en
cumbre encima sienten miedo cuando
sienten miedo y cómo combaten el miedo
el miedo es real si yo pienso que hemos
tenido miedo muchos momentos
especialmente cuando ya tenemos que
partir porque muchas veces antes de ir a
la cumbre a la primera montaña todos
hemos tenido miedo porque desconocíamos
era algo que desconocíamos que tal vez
lo hemos soñado mucho tiempo pero no
había cuando lo logremos nos hemos
tenido que armar del valor y decir ahora
es cuando ahora de una vez de una vez
intentaremos
y ese miedo creo que lo hemos superado
porque cada una ha estado acompañada o
acompañada desde un ser querido en el
caso de mis compañeras sus esposos
yo no tengo esposo estoy soltera todavía
ah
y en mi caso mi papá y mi papá llama me
hace volver niña de nuevo y cuando
escalamos más montañas aquí en bolivia
sentimos esa confianza de tener ese
contacto con la montaña con la
naturaleza con la pachamama con el hacha
chila al menos yo siento que que nos
recibe nos quiere y yo siento un gran
cariño y amor por las montañas como
alguien decía también en el vídeo
estamos enamoradas de las montañas
entonces eso nos da confianza para haber
escalado aquí todas las montañas en
bolivia pero cuando fuimos a mendoza
creo que ha sido el miedo más grande que
hemos atravesado porque era otra gente
era otra otra montaña no sabíamos cómo
era teníamos que estar como 20 días
aproximadamente no sabíamos lo que nos
esperaba y era representar a toda
bolivia y sacar también a las mujeres en
alto entonces ahí es donde hemos sentido
mucho miedo mientras más íbamos subiendo
acampando cada cada campamento entonces
sentíamos y ahora que viene que será que
pasará y si no lo logramos esos miedos
sentimos pero nos armamos de valor y
decimos no tenemos que seguir tenemos
que seguir tenemos que luchar por
nuestros sueños
[Aplausos]
si te ves para completar un poquito
muchas todas mamas algunas abuelas en el
caso de lydia y dora tenemos una vida
normal como la de ustedes no de estar
ocupadas toda la mañana algunos ayudando
también a los nietos llevar a la escuela
en mi caso yo trabajo como maestra en la
tarde tenemos tiempo libre y tenemos que
estar haciendo otras cosas siempre muy
activas y siempre cada fin de semana
cada que se puede siempre vamos a la
montaña eso sí no podemos dejar no a
veces entrenamos de manera personal y
cuando ya nos reunimos como grupo y
tenemos algún proyecto de escalar o
subir algún ascenso nos reunimos y vamos
entonces es una rutina que siempre lo
practicamos a día
[Música]
bueno para mí en la montaña es lo más
hermoso
que me ha podido suceder a mí escalar ya
estas montañas
yo creo que ahora sin las montañas no
puedo vivir
me ha traído una felicidad
más que toda mi vida
por qué
[Aplausos]
a los años que tengo
estoy haciendo lo que yo quiero bien
dicho
van a disculpar un poquito y oyeron es
siempre este
pero eso es la montaña para mí
cuando mi edad
estoy haciendo lo que yo quiero y quiero
seguir escalando más montañas hasta
donde dios me brindé me diga hasta ahí
vas a ir y bueno yo quiero seguir yendo
a las montañas y hacer este próximo
proyecto que tenemos el everest
[Aplausos]
lista quisiera que nos cuenten esa
primera vez yo creo que la primera vez
que ustedes ve encima es muy especial
de hecho he escuchado varias anécdotas
de ustedes acerca de eso de esa
curiosidad de ir a verlo por ustedes
mismas no a veces
no las cuentan pero no es lo mismo
hacerlo uno verlo uno si ya me estoy
recordando para mí ha sido muy especial
porque de niña siempre le pregunta a mi
papá para ti que hay en la cima porque
llevas a los turistas que sacan viendo
ahí porque te veo tan cansada
y me decía no tienes que ver los sacamos
fuego y nada más pero parece entonces
para mí no era nada más no pero me
decías bien sacrificas bien sacrificado
ya bueno pero cuando llegué por primera
vez
sentido
he tenido los recuerdos de mi niñez y ha
sentido una felicidad enorme de haber
llegado de haber
en un momento decía tal vez no voy a
poder o me da miedo lo voy a volver qué
sé yo que espero que me esperara allá no
pensaba de que yo era capaz en muchos
momentos les decía no mejor o no hoy
estaba indecisa pero esa indecisión en
un momento lo echó a un lado y cuando ya
estaba ya dije
y yo había sido capaz de esto y creo que
puedo mucho más y es así que montaña
tras montaña he logrado llegar gracias a
dios gracias a la ayuda también del
grupo de las compañeras a la cima y
tocar ayala cóncava ha sido para mí un
poco lo más duro llegar a la cima ha
sido una alegría igual enorme
pero eso sentir sentí mucha mucha
tranquilidad mucha paz - me ha enseñado
mucho la montaña a partir de ese día mi
vida ha cambiado prácticamente en
resumidas cuentas
[Aplausos]
bueno yo antes escala subía hasta campo
alto y junto con mis hermanos mis
hermanas yo iba de porteador de ayudante
de cocina y yo le decía a mis hermanos a
mi hermana porque no podemos subir a la
montaña a la cumbre
mis hermanos me decían que no vas a
poder con la pollera no me decían y si
sé decir pero ya después que mis
compañeras se habían animado a subir a
la cumbre de huayna potosí yo de esa
manera yo me animé a escala tenían a la
cumbre pero después que logrado así a la
cima de la cumbre en llegar
ha sido un emocionante que nunca había
pensado en llegar a la cima
ahora quisiera para ir terminando quiero
quiero por favor invitar a cecilia adora
a helio que suban al escenario
bienvenida sexy
y ahora muchas gracias ahora
y el yo para se concedió el yo soy
instructor así que yo me voy a pasar por
acá atrás perdón
bueno
con esta imagen y queremos cerrar
quisiéramos que las cinco se separen acá
para una foto oficial para que ellas
puedan posar les pueden sacar una super
foto esto es brillante de hadas
estamos muy felices de tenerlas apoyen
su peli cuando salgan todas vayan a
verlas
[Aplausos]
[Música]